dreadnought is younger developments
Armada sized answer to cockpit
simulators whereas most space Sims place
you with the helm of the ship about as
large as an x-wing the aptly named
dreadnought gives you control of
something a little more akin to a Star
Destroyer they may be big and slow but
bringing one of these 10-ton beryllium
bastards to the ground is more
satisfying than popping all the bubble
wrap in the Amazon warehouse so we're
helping you pick the right ship clasp to
prevent an altar on repeat oh all the
wrong the Corvette is described as the
Millennium Falcon of dreadnought it uses
maneuverability and speed to flank
distract dodge and hit and run the other
heavier ships in the game well your
agility may be an advantage here don't
stop moving or you won't be making the
Kessel run in 12 parsecs for long all
right I promise that's the last bad star
worship the eponymous dreadnought is
obviously the largest of the classes it
can be outfitted to deploy smaller
fighters to do its bidding or rely on
devastating broadside cannons to rip
foes from the sky like a future pirate
ship further the heavy armor of the
dreadnought allows it to outlast other
ships in a battle though you'll
sacrifice much of your speed for
survivability the Destroyer is your
all-purpose all-around battleship it's
not as powerful as the dread-nots and
not as fast as the Corvette but it
offers a stable middle ground and can
balance the polarity of the other
classes this is the ideal class for
beginners to dip their toes into the
waters of intergalactic warfare the
tactical cruisers dread-nots support
class its laser beam can deal damage
with the best of them but redirected
towards a friendly ship and lo and
behold it turns green and becomes
healing beam you can also focus this
beam to either heal or deal damage more
efficiently but this makes your shipment
were susceptible to damage so use it
wisely
finally the artillery Cruiser is the
longest range ship in dreadnought it
relies on a heavy slow firing railgun
that's punishing on misses but
delightfully destructive when you make
contact it's hard to be stealthy when
you're piloting a mile-long piece of
titanium with your artillery classes
your best bet for keeping a safe
distance
dreadnought is shaping up to be one of
the more unique offerings in the space
sim genre so keep your eyes peeled for
updates and we'll bring you details as
they emerge stay frosty out there
captain
you
[Music]